getting into character is no joke so
I've compiled a list of actors that have
taken things way too far on set we're
talking scary hospital visits committing
actual heinous crimes and sleeping
inside the carcass of an animal to
withstand below freezing weather yeah
let's unpack this it wouldn't be a video
about method acting if I didn't bring up
Keith Ledger's Joker performance
on my face did you know that he locked
himself away in a London hotel for a
month writing daily diary entries as the
Caped Crusaders arch nemesis there was
even a time in Brokeback Mountain where
he was supposed to turn into an Alleyway
and cry into a wall but he ended up
punching the brick with such force that
he really seriously injured his hand
dude literally stalked a woman for
acting research Jamie Dornan was method
acting his crime drama series The Fall
where he plays a serial killer he is a
relatively normal person outside of the
murders so he could better understand
the mind of such a person he purposely
stopped a woman he saw on the London
Underground he was on the train with her
and she ended up getting off a few stops
before he was planning so he got off
with her and followed her around while
she walked the streets he said though he
wasn't proud of his actions he said he
felt dirty that he did learn something
valuable when it came to playing the
character Ashton Kutcher took things a
little too far when it came to getting
into character for his role as Steve
Jobs do you know why people buy an Apple
why do they buy an apple not the
competitor the 2013 biographical film
jobs shows the early collaboration
between Steve Jobs and Steve Wozniak so
obviously he spent a ton of hours doing
research on Steve Jobs life even Landing
himself in the hospital after trying to
mimic his questionable eating habits
Ashton Kutcher ended up in the hospital
not once but twice with pancreatitis
trying to eat like Steve Jobs one
instance included him only eating grapes
for every meal yeah definitely a bit too
far in that regard I couldn't possibly
get into every insane method acting
experience Robert De Niro has had but
for starts when he was preparing for his
role in Taxi Driver he actually worked
12-hour days as a New York City cab
driver that might not seem ridiculous
but let's talk about the fact that when
he starred in Cape Fear he paid a
dentist to actually grind his teeth down
in order to get into his psychopath
stalker character Leonardo DiCaprio's
first Oscar in his entire career came
after four decades for his role in the
Revenant I don't think I'd ever want to
an award like this after learning about
everything Leonardo went through for it
this particular experience was a pretty
memorable profound difficult one
Leonardo typically a vegetarian ate raw
bison slept in an animal carcass and
underwent insanely freezing temperatures
so he could portray the rugged character
Johnny Depp is notorious for his method
acting when he was preparing for his
role In Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas
he spent years studying Hunter S
Thompson he actually even lived in
Hunter's basement sleeping and smoking
next to barrels of gunpowder and
spending most of his time reading old
transcripts from the author Hilary Swank
spent a month preparing for her role and
Boys Don't Cry the tragic story of
Brandon Tina she actually lived her life
as a man for that entire month cutting
off her hair wearing binders and putting
socks down the front of her jeans
apparently her longtime neighbors
thought she invited her brother to come
live with her for a while well yeah
that's super method the most insane
thing that happened while she was
preparing for the role happened right
before 4 million dollar baby she was
spending six days a week in the gym for
months packing on 20 pounds of pure
muscle so engulfed in her regime that
she didn't even notice when a massive
blister exploded on her foot after
seeing a doctor they told her she had a
staph infection that was only a few
hours away from reaching her heart scary
Rooney Mara did some major modifications
for her role in The Girl with the Dragon
Tattoo she bleached her eyebrows cut her
hair short got her eyebrows nose lip and
nipples pierced it was really important
to her to have these modifications as
sort of like a second costume because
there's so much nudity in the film when
I don't have my clothes on it's like
it's not my body like I am still in
character she also learned to skateboard
train in martial arts and learned to
ride a motorcycle there's also this
insane scene she did in the movie a
ghost story where her character eats an
entire chocolate pie by herself in a
single take before running to the
bathroom in getting sick Rooney Mara
said that was her first and last time
tasting pie I can't say I blame her for
that whoever said acting is a fun job
these actors changed their hair their
body underwent extreme conditions and
almost even lost their lives because of
some of these roles which role do you
think was the most challenging is there
anyone else you think should have been
on this list
[Music]